so i know a lot of you have been asking  for a master bedroom tour so this is my  parents room they decorated it about  like 10 years ago so please stop with  the it's outdated comments my mom  actually corrected me i guess it was 20  years ago not 10 so it was even longer  than i thought but this is the main  bathroom what i think the coolest part  of the bathroom is that there is a  walk-in shower on top of that my mom has  this beautiful walk-in closet like i  mean i guess it's my dad's too but you  guys get it  there's also this bathtub  and a little  bathroom room another cool thing is that  they have their own porch to themselves  this is the tour from the backyard so  you can see the pond over there and this  is the full backyard and then finally  this used to be the baby room but now  it's just an extra room for if my dad  wants to take a nap or something or if  there's like guests here